35 ans séparent ces deux archives et le
contraste est frappant à gauche kaboul
en 1961 les femmes ont le visage
découvert elles travaillent et étudient
à droite ni kaboul en 1996 les talibans
viennent de prendre le pouvoir en
afghanistan et leur arrivée pose une
question quelles conditions de vie pour
les femmes est-ce que vous vous sentez
prisonnière d'un système intégristes
bien sûr c'est ce qu'on ressent
maintenant mais on espère que dans le
futur nous femmes afghanes retrouverons
nos droits
partout dans le pays les talibans font
appliquer la loi islamique la charia les
femmes en droit à rien ni au travail ni
aux voyages aux études impossible pour
elle de quitter seule leur domicile
elles sont aussi obligés de porter un
voile intégral le tchadri vous les
étrangers nous accusé d'interdire le
travail des femmes mais moi je vous
réponds les mollahs d'un chef décide ce
qui est bon pour les femmes
face à l'oppression des talibans
certaines femmes n'en peuvent plus elle
tente de résister et risquent leur vie
zalla est l'une d'entre elles elle fait
partie de rawa l'association
révolutionnaire des femmes afghanes leur
mission organiser des écoles
clandestines pour les filles sur ces
images les journalistes de l'époque on
flouté leurs visages car elles aussi
sont menacés nous éduquons les femmes en
organisant des cours sur leurs droits
fondamentaux les sciences sociales on
essaie de leur inculquer une vraie
conscience politique
décembre 2001 les talibans sont chassés
du pouvoir mais leur départ ne marque
pas pour autant la fin totale des
restrictions dans certaines régions leur
doctrine est toujours présente difficile
encore de se découvrir pour certaines
femmes comme ici à kaboul je la hais ce
voile c'est pascal jallet des tests
mais la résistance continue à l'image de
malalai joya elle a été députée afghane
de 2005 à 2007 une fonction impensable
quelques années plus tôt mais au
parlement elle n'était pas respecté sa
parole dérangeait son micro était
régulièrement coupées des hommes la
menace et pour la faire taire elle a
aussi échappé à plusieurs tentatives
d'assassinât en 2010 elle appelait à
l'aide
s'il vous plaît aidez nous à éduquer les
afghans autant que vous pouvez car
l'éducation est la clé de l'émancipation
ces femmes qui commettent des attentats
suicide si elle est éduquée jamais elle
n'irait se faire exploser elle ferait
comme moi elle résiste et reste p stade
vingt ans après leur départ en 2001 les
talibans sont revenus au pouvoir mais
certaines femmes ont décidé de faire
face à et rate dans l'ouest du pays mais
aussi à kaboul la capitale
elles ont manifesté pour défendre leurs
droits